oh Nate silver that's I think we need to
talk about that after you leave silver
um his great take on the um he says this
morning oh here's your take yeah g whiz
for a guy that claims to be smart nature
sure is dumb Courtney Nate silver covid
just magically appeared around the world
no help to people traveling just poof
um he really is forgetting again that
that this is also the guy that I'm sure
if you looked up tweets you would find
the ones where he talks about getting
into close spaces and wearing masks in
the early like August 2020. so you know
I I will say I've said it before and
I'll say it again kovid really [ __ ]
with people's heads okay right they it
changed the way that they looked at
reality it changed the way they had to
look at politics uh Society other people
and and how they approach it and
unfortunately it did [ __ ] with their
heads where
whether it was covet itself or the you
know just the the situation of being in
a pandemic they
just threw everything out of the [ __ ]
window it was like all sense of logic
and reasoning went right out we don't
want to trust doctors the doctors we do
want to trust aren't actually board
certified or are some crazy uh Alien DNA
sperm uh you know Satan uh type of uh uh
of um
beliefs right like these are the people
it's also the one that Trump was like oh
yeah she's got some good stuff doctor
are they still are these the same aliens
that are going to bring JFK Jr back down
so he can run with trump it might be I
don't know you know they they probe to
reveal JK Jr and they probed it right
you know maybe give you the vaccine I
don't really just saying you're saying I
know I know it's a q Anon World we're
just living in it hey just asking
questions okay right you know inquiry
minds want to know more boneheaded about
Nate Silver's tweet because I think his
his tweet's kind of bone-headed right um
and if you go read my Tweet and
basically I'm like because he says the
average American spends like five hours
uh per year on a plane I said uh the
average American spends like five
seconds a year listening to Nate silver
um is what I said but more than that
it's the decision from the judge that is
actually really [ __ ] bone-headed now
right you can disagree and argue the
whole [ __ ] but the context of who the
judge is really matters well that is
true but here's the the one [ __ ]
sentence that the judge has in there is
she's like well the only thing that a
mass does is catch the the droplets with
the with the with the coronavirus in it
the particles in it that way well yeah
that's the whole [ __ ] the whole [ __ ]
point is for the mass to catch the
disease and the mass so it doesn't
spread to someone else like you just
said what the mask does they do that
though they run right into the [ __ ]
point head first every time
they're like so in summation uh the mask
actually does work right but we're not
gonna require it yeah so Nate silver
over here is like oh well you know uh
the margin or whatever he said well yeah
he's basically he's basically saying
he's basically saying if a few people
get sick it's not gonna make an overall
difference right which on an age does
right exactly a few people got sick they
travel right now whether you want to
debate it was on the plane or not but
the fact that you were going into a
highly concentrated pact I I I like
Margie here's in summation
that you're really you're really digging
a game there Margie you're becoming one
of my favorite yeah I just I just felt
like that would be what she would say
she would be like in summation in
summation
um is that is it that your your benches
he probably like here we go
I just doesn't even wear glasses so I
just do this like how do you know he
might
anyway anyway what I'm what I'm saying
here is Nate silver like he goes oh a
few people here and there doesn't really
matter in the grand scheme of things
however that same type of thinking of
like oh well a few people here and there
well that's how it all started right you
look at it and you say Well only a few
people had covet right wasn't a big deal
it's not like for it's not like life or
death or something like that right well
there's only there was only a couple
people that died somebody coughed
somebody sneezed somebody breathed
somebody spoke droplets go somewhere
that person gets it that person goes to
see family it's like
um if anyone out there who's listening
or watching has seen
um Rise of the Planet of the Apes right
at the at the end of the movie what ends
up happening is the guy who works at the
clinic gets he gets a
uh um
like a dosage of the the the treatment
that they were giving the the
chimpanzees right he gets sick because
it's not meant for humans that guy goes
to uh uh James Franco's house coughs on
the neighbor that neighbor's a pilot at
the end of the movie that neighbor goes
and travels so he goes to the airport
and then you see this whole thing spread
and it's literally a a representation of
what happened well I mean here's the
thing
the thing that Nate silver and even this
judge
um is is really
and I think Americans or anyone who is
either anti-mask or probas whatever you
want to say I think the one thing that
we're discounting here is the judge said
some really stupid [ __ ] in this decision
but if you're going to make a case like
if you're really going to make a case
for not having mask on public
transportation which honestly the case
should be why is it such a big deal if
we do it for a little bit longer right
number one it's not it's not affecting
anyone negatively if we have another six
months or years worth of data on the
vaccine because I think that's the
actual best case to make to not have a
mask on like that is the best case to be
made is that the bad vaccine has proven
to be very effective it has been proven
to be very effective in that it you will
not you will not pass away and you will
not be hospitalized now there are people
out there who still do get sick and
still get hospitalized and some die
right even with the vaccine but those
are the ones on the far margin so that
is truly the argument to be made this
judge did not make the vaccine argument
and the reason why is because the judge
is anti-mask she's anti-vaccine because
the context that you were talking about
earlier is not only is she a trump
appointed judge she's one of the ones
that they said she's not qualified right
be a federal judge 33 and they're you
know I think there's like 22 people that
have ever that have been uh
or of of the people that have been
nominated and appointed to a lifetime
federal judge federal judge position 22
have been deemed as not qualified and
she was one of them right and it's it
should be notice no surprise to anyone
that somebody like there's a theme going
on here like call me crazy but there's a
theme that when Trump appoints someone
puts someone in a cabinet position put
someone under Federal position put
someone or nominate someone for anything
else or even says I endorse this person
like Dr Oz who's [ __ ] a quack doctor
these people are not qualified they are
terrible people who don't know what
they're doing and they're given high
ranking positions that can impact the
lives or or or policies of many people
and as a result
especially a federal lifetime position
you are now and not only that but also
one who's 33 years old for a lifetime
you're talking about setting rules and
precedence up by the judge for years to
come that will impact the lives of
tons and tons of people
and so again there's a theme call me
crazy but it seems like Trump appoints
and nominates or endorses people who are
just not qualified and [ __ ] over
everyone else that's what it is well I
want to say one more thing before you
jump because Margie and she makes a a
point here one judge shouldn't have the
power to affect every singer travel and
that's Margie as much as that may not be
true or good or bad the judge and I
think there's the point Gabe's trying to
make if you are a qualified judge you
should be able to make decisions that
affect every single traveler but make it
for the good of every single traveler
not for the bad of every single driver I
think that's the point and that's why
it's so important that we keep the
messaging up we participate in our
democracy we beat pro-democracy for this
2020 mid 2022 midterm is so not to elect
morons like Dr Oz or or the guy who
loves America's Hitler JD Vance which
I'm going to show a video about that
when we come back Gabe thanks for
joining us today we'll see you tomorrow
and stick around everyone we'll be right
back with the JD Vance loves Hitler
video we'll be right back after this